FIRST HEARING OF THE SENATE
HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE FOR
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO LEGISLATIVE SESSION
I AM HONORED TO RETURN AS CHAIR
OF THIS COMMITTEE AND I'D LIKE
TO WOULD NOT ACKNOWLEDGE FUMER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. ARE HERE
TODAY. OUR VICE CHAIR JONES WHO
WILL JOIN US- AT SOME POINT IN
THE HEARING ARE AND THEN WE
HAVE SENATOR PENN WAS BACK
JOINING US ON THIS COMMITTEE AS
WELL. AND WE ALSO LIKE TO
WELCOME OUR NEWEST MEMBER OF
THIS COMMITTEE SENATOR DAVE
CORTES HE WELCOMED. ARE THE
PAST YEAR HAS CHALLENGED US TO
IN. IN WAYS WE COULD NOT HAVE
CONCEIVED- IT COVER NINETEEN
HAS EXPOSED HOLES IN OUR SAFETY
NET AND OUR PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN
TESTED AND IN WAYS WE COULD
HAVE NEVER IMAGINED. OUR CHILD
CARE SYSTEM HAS BEEN CHALLENGED
TO SAFE TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
FAMILIES. MORE PEOPLE THAN EVER
ARE IN NEED OF NUTRITION
ASSISTANCE LIKE CALFRESH FOOD
BANK SERVICES AND SENIOR MEAL
PROGRAMS. OLDER CALIFORNIANS IN
THOSE LIVING WITH DISABILITIES
HAVE BEEN LIVING IN ISOLATION
AND PEER. BUT WE WILL CONTINUE
TO DO THE HARD WORK TO ENSURE
THAT PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA ARE
PROVIDED THE SERVICES AND
SUPPORT CITY TO LIVE HEALTHY
AND PRODUCTIVE LIVES. NOW MORE
THAN EVER THE POLICY DECISIONS
MADE IN THIS COMMITTEE ARE
CONSEQUENTIAL TO THE WELL
BEING. OF SOME OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS.
INCLUDING PEOPLE LIVING IN
POVERTY FAMILIES IN NEED OF AID
AND SERVICES. CHILDREN AND
YOUTH WHO ARE AT RISK FOR
NEGLECT OR ABUSE. PEOPLE LIVING
WITH DISABILITIES OLDER ADULTS
AND THEIR CAREGIVERS. I AM
PLEASED TO KNOW THAT. THERE IS
MORE CORPORATE RELIEF COMING
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BUT
THERE IS MUCH THAT CAN BE DONE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. I LOOK
FORWARD TO PARTNER WITH MY
COLLEAGUES. IN THE CAPITAL AND
WITH LEADERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AS WE WORK TO PROTECT
HUMAN SERVICES PROGRAMS AND
EXPLORE HOW WE CAN BE MORE
EFFICIENT. AND USER FRIENDLY TO
THE PEOPLE WE SERVE. AT THIS
MOMENT I'D LIKE TO GO AHEAD AND-
ESTABLISH QUORUM. SO IN
RESPONSE TO COVER NINETEEN
EMERGENCY TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERING TONIGHT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO ONE OR TWO HEARING ROOMS TO
THE EXTENT THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW I
WILL BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY. ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. FOUR EIGHT ONE ZERO
ONE ONE EIGHT. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TOWARDS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE AND OR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION. PROCESS
ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER THIS
CAN BE SHORT WAIT. ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU
WILL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE
ON YOU AND YOU WERE NOT READY
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID. BECAUSE TO BE BACK YOU
MUST MEET THE DEVICE YOU ARE
WATCHING. THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY. AT ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE
MAYBE BE REMOVED FROM THE
REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE
THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE
EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE TO HEAR PROCESS AND
CONDUCTOR HEARINGS AND AS CLOSE
TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE ARE MAYBE SOME
LACK TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS
WORK ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE
OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENTS ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
R. TODAY WE HAVE FIVE BILLS ON
OUR AGENDA. AND AT THIS MOMENT
I'D LIKE TO START WITH
ESTABLISHING A QUORUM. I'D LIKE
TO REMIND MEMBERS TO RETURN TO
TURN ON THEIR MICROPHONE TO
SPEAK INTO INTO THEM THROUGHOUT
THE HEARING. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FOR TARO. PRESIDENT JONES
I'M HERE. CORTESE PAN I HAVE A
QUORUM. OKAY A QUORUM HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED AND NOW WE WILL
START BY ADOPTING OUR COMMITTEE
RULES THE RULES HAVE BEEN
PROVIDED TO ALL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE REVIEW
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL ADOPT THE COMMITTEE RULES
FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO LEGISLATIVE
SESSION. HEARING N OBJECTIONS
THE COMMITTEE RULES ARE ADOPTED.
WE WILL NOW- ONE HANDED OVER TO
OUR VICE CHAIR FOR A FEW WORDS.
GREAT THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
WOMAN I AM COLLEGES IS JUST THE
BEGINNING OF THE MEETING AS
DOWN JUDICIARY ADVISING THEM
AND I'LL BE UP HERE- IN- I HAVE
THE- UNIQUE HONOR OF SERVING ON
TWO COMMITTEES AT THE SAME TIME
SO I MAKE QUITE ABLE TO CLONE
MYSELF YET BUT WE'RE WORKING
ON. BUT I DO SO ALSO JUST WANNA
SAY THANKS TO THE CHAIRWOMAN
WE'VE HAD A GREAT- WORKING
RELATIONSHIP ON THIS COMMITTEE
IS THE ONLY REPUBLICAN ON THE
COMMITTEE. I CONSIDER THAT A
DISTINCT HONOR AND- WE HAD SOME
VERY POSITIVE- CONVERSATIONS
LAST YEAR AND- IDEAS THAT WE
WORKED ON WELL TOGETHER. I LOOK
FORWARD TO THE NEW MAKE UP OF
THE COMMITTEE THIS YEAR-
WELCOMING CENTER CORTESE TO
THE- COMMITTEE AND- LIKE.
CONTINUING THAT. EFFORT OF
COLLABORATION. WE HAD SOME WE
HAD SOME GOOD IN FOR
INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS OVER THE
IN TERM THAT I THINK- SOME GOOD
IDEAS. FOR STREAMLINING
GOVERNMENT CALIFORNIA I THINK
WE BOTH RECOGNIZE SOME NEEDS
THERE THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
WORK ON. AND I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO DOING WHATEVER WE
CANNOT THROUGH THIS COMMITTEE
TO PROTECT THE MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS. OF OUR GREAT STATE
OF CALIFORNIA SO THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SAY HELLO.
THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR- AT
THIS MOMENT WE WILL GO AHEAD
AND MOVE TOWARDS AUTHOR
PRESENTATION OF THE PHILS. AT
WE WILL. ALL RIGHT TO THE
OFFICE ALREADY DID YEAH OKAY
OKAY OKAY STARTED WORKING- I.
THANK YOU SO AT THIS MOMENT I
WILL- THAT WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON OVER TO AGENDA ITEM NUMBER.
SIX FOUR SB THREE EIGHT FOUR.
BOB SENATE QUARTERS IT PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO BEGIN WHENEVER YOU
ARE READY. THE THIRTY
MILLIMETER HELLO IN A MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE- ALTHOUGH
EXISTING LAW REQUIRES SOCIAL
WORKERS IN PROBATION OFFICERS
TO EXERCISE DUE DILIGENCE IN
THEIR INVESTIGATION IDENTIFY
LOCATE AND NOTIFY RELATIVES OF
CHILDREN TAKEN IN CUSTODY.
CALIFORNIA STILL FALLS FLAT AND
PLACING THESE CHILDREN IN THE
CARE OF A RELATIVE. OF ALL
CHILDREN REMOVED FROM PARENTAL
CARE ONLY ABOUT 32% ARE PLACED
WITH RELATIVES. RESEARCH
DEMONSTRATES THAT RELATIVE
PLACEMENT RESULTS IN BETTER
EMOTIONAL PHYSICAL OUTCOMES FOR
YOUTH WHEN COMPARED TO FOSTER
CARE CONCRETE CARE. IN STATE
AND FEDERAL LAW EVEN INCLUDE A
PREFERENCE FOR REAL TO
PLACEMENT. HOWEVER ROLE TO
PLACES RELY ON THE EFFORTS MADE
BY SOCIAL WORKERS IN PROBATION
OFFICERS TO LOCATE AND CONNECT
YOUTH WITH THOSE RELATIVES. SB
THREE FOUR SIX TO ADDRESS THIS
BY REQUIRING COUNTIES TO
UTILIZE FAMILY FINDING THEIR
EFFORTS TO LOCATE POTENTIAL
ROLE TO PLACEMENTS FOR YOUTH.
FAMILY FINING IS A POWERFUL
TOOL ALREADY AT THE DISPOSAL OF
COUNTIES THAT CAN INCLUDE
SEARCHING FOR RELATIVES USING A
COMPUTER BASED SEARCH ENGINE.
USING THE CHILD AS A PRIMARY
INFORMATION SOURCE AND
CONDUCTING IMMEDIATE IN PERSON
INTERVIEWS OF ALL PERSPECTIVE
RELATIVE CAREGIVERS. SB THREE
FOR THE FAMILY FINE ACT AIMS TO
ENCOURAGE THE USE OF FAMILY
FINDING. BY ADDING FAMILY
FINDING TO THE DEFINITION OF
DUE DILIGENCE AND RECORDING
COUNTY WALTER DEPARTMENTS TO
REPORT. IT TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES IN THE STATE
FOSTER CARE HOMES BIRDS PERSON
WHAT PRACTICES FOR FAMILY
FINING THE COUNTY HAS
IMPLEMENTED. STRENGTHENING
FAMILY FIGHTING EFFORTS MADE BY
COUNTIES WILL RESULT IN MORE
CHILDREN BEING PLACED IN A
PERMANENT HOME. AND THEREFORE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESERVE
THEIR CULTURAL IDENTITY. AND
CONNECTIONS TO THEIR COMMUNITY.
MAINTAINING BETTER PHYSICAL AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH IN UNDERGOING
LAW SCHOOL CHANGES- I ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. HERE TO TESTIFY TODAY- WE
HAVE MIKE BELOW THE END OF. A
JUROR SAID IS RECOGNIZED UP AND
DOWN THE STATE IS AN EXPERT IN
THIS AREA SUPERIOR RETURNS PER
COURT JUDGE LEONARD EDWARDS.
THANK YOU MANAGER. THANK YOU WE
WILL NOW OPEN IT UP TO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION. DO YOU CAN DO TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
AND CONSIDERATIONS CLEANING
PROTOCOLS WE WILL INSTITUTE
TIME LIMITS ON TESTIMONY.
EARNING WE WITNESS IN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION WILL BE LIMITED
TO THREE MINUTES EACH ALL
OTHERS WISHING TO TESTIFIED
REPUBLIC COMMENT MUST LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURES. AND- PLEASE I FEEL
FREE TO BEGIN- MISTER BELOVED.
THANK YOU SENATOR- MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS IT IS MIKE BELOW ON
BEHALF OF THE JUVENILE COURT
JUDGES OF CALIFORNIA EIGHT
SECTION OF THE CALIFORNIA
JUDGES ASSOCIATION VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE HEARING AND THE
VERY THOROUGH AND FIND
ANALYSIS- A PREPARED BY MAY
SHAKE. WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
BILL IS THE CONTINUATION OF
LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS ON FINDING
THE RELATIVE PLACEMENTS. OR FOR
WHICH- RESEARCH SUGGESTS
PROVIDE FAR BETTER OUTCOMES FOR
USE THAT AND- AND CONGREGATE
CARE OR- WHAT FOSTER CARE- THIS
IS NOT AT ALL TO- SPEAK IN
DEROGATION OR DENIGRATION OF
OUR- FINE FOSTER PARENTS IN
CALIFORNIA. YOUR TO SUGGEST
THAT SOCIAL WORKERS AND
PROBATION OFFICERS IN THE
DEPENDENCY AND DELINQUENCY
AREAS ARE NOT. DOING THEIR BEST
RATHER WE JUST BELIEVE THAT
EVERY POSSIBLE APPROACH OUGHT
TO BE EMPLOYED IN FINDING
RELATIVE PLACEMENTS. AND SO WE
THINK THIS IS A CONTINUATION OF
THE WORK DONE BY THE
LEGISLATURE IN RECENT YEARS
INCLUDING. A BILL A FEW YEARS
AGO BY SENATOR JACKSON. WITHOUT
WE WOULD ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AND WITH US TODAY I HOPE IS-
JUDGE LAND EDWARDS SAYING-
YOU'RE GONNA COURT JUDGE OF
TREMENDOUS RENOWNED FROM SANTA
CLARA COUNTY. SO. I WOULD HOPE
THAT- JUDGE EDWARD IS WITH US
AND CAN SPEAK FOR JUST A MOMENT.
MISTER EDWARDS A PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO BEGIN IF YOU ARE
READING. MADAM CHAIR IT WAS A
MICHELADA AGAIN I WILL I DID
HAVE A LITTLE DIFFICULTY
GETTING THROUGH ON THE SYSTEM
SO IT'S POSSIBLE THAT JUDGE
EDWARDS HAS HAD THAT PROBLEM IF
SO WE APOLOGIZE BUT WOULD AGAIN
ASK FOR AN I. OKAY THINKING.
EVERYWHERE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
I'MI'M HERE I DISCIPLINE
EDWARDS. CAN YOU HEAR ME. YOU
SPEAK UP JUST A BIT MORE PLEASE.
YES THIS IS LAND EDWARDS CAN
YOU HEAR ME WE CAN HEAR YOU NOW.
PLEASE PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU
ARE READY THANK YOU. I AM
SPEAKING TO YOU ALL TODAY ABOUT
S. B. THREE EIGHT FOUR. THIS IS
A- MODEST THE PROPOSAL IT'S A
CONTINUATION OF LEGISLATION
THAT THIS GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN
PASSING FOR THE PAST FIFTEEN
YEARS. IT INVOLVES FAMILY
FINDING AND IMPROVE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF FAMILY FINDING
IN CALIFORNIA. ANY ONE HAS ANY
QUESTIONS I AM READY TO ANSWER
THEM. YEAH THANK YOU- A THIS
MOMENT WE WILL- OPEN UP PUBLIC
COMMENT IN SUPPORT AND WE WILL
BEGIN HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO
ZERO THREE. TO HAVE. ANY ANYONE
HERE TO WANT TO TESTIFY ON THIS
BILL IMPROVE. FORTY TWO ZERO
THREE THREE NINE. CAN WE TAKE A
LOOK AT ROOM TWENTY FORTY. SEE
NON CAN WE OPEN UP THE
TELEPHONE LINE UP FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA TELECONFERENCE RUBIS. AND
JUST AS A REMINDER TO THOSE WHO
ARE WAITING ON THE PHONE PLEASE
LIMIT YOUR TESTIMONY TO NAME
AFFILIATION IN YOUR POSITION ON
THE BILL. MODERATOR PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
EIGHT FOUR AND PROVIDE THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT PLEASE.
SURE LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SHOW SUPPORT PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO NOW AGAIN TO SHOW
SUPPORT. PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
NOW. AND WE DO HAVE A ONE IN
THE QUEUE. WEBER TRYING TWELVE
WE'VE GONE AHEAD. HI THIS IS
KELLY WITH THE WHILE DIRECTOR
OF. WITH THE AMENDMENTS BEING
TAKEN TODAY IN COMMITTEE WE ARE
ABLE TO SUPPORT THE BILL THANK
YOUNG. THANK YOU MODERATOR CAN
RESTRICT. GO AHEAD. SORRY WE
HAVE ABOUT THE MARKET THAT HAD
HE WOULD UP AGAIN AS A REMINDER
TO SHOW SUPPORT WHY NOT BEEN
FERAL WILL MOVE TO LINE FORTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS BRIDGET FROM OPEN HEART
KITCHEN IN LIVERMORE CALIFORNIA.
THE POINT SB ONE ON SEVEN.
BROWN'S MA'AM I THE MALL WE'RE
TAKING PUT COMMENT SUPPORT OF
SB. THREE EIGHT FOUR. BUT IT
TOOK COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE EIGHT FOR THE MOMENT.
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE CHECK
THE LINE ONCE AGAIN. YES LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN TO SHOW SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
IN THE TO SUPPORT FOR AT YEAR
THREE EIGHT FOUR. WELL MOVE TO
LINE SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SANTA BARBARA BEHALF OF SEIU
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL AS AMENDED. AND THERE'S NO
ONE ELSE THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
OKAY THANK YOU MODERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE JUST CHECK ONE MORE
TIME- TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE
HEARD FROM ALL THE SUPPORT
WITNESSES ON SB. THREE EIGHT
FOUR. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
AGAIN TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR S. B.
THREE EIGHT FOUR PRESS ONE AND
THEN THERE ARE NOW AGAIN ONE
THEN ZERO TO SHOW SUPPORT. AND
THERE'S NO ONE IN THE QUEUE.
THANK YOU MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE OPEN THE LINES AND
CALLED SUPPORT. ALLARDYCE
HAVING HEARD FROM ALL THE
SUPPORTERS WILL NOW FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS IN HERE FROM ANY-
ANYONE OPPOSED TO SB THREE FOUR.
DO YOU HAVE ANY- ANYONE OPPOSED
TO SB THREE FOREIGN AND FROM.
FORTY TWO ZERO THREE. THREE
NINE CAN WE GO TO OUR ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. SEEN NONE. CAN WE
CAN WE OPEN UP- PUBLIC COMMENT
IN OPPOSITION AND THAT BE THE
TELEPHONE LINES. YEAH LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU OPPOSE SB
THREE EIGHT FOUR PRESS ONE THEN
THERE ARE NOW AGAIN TO OPPOSED
M. B. THREE EIGHT FOUR ONE THEN
THERE ARE NOW. AND THERE'S NO
ONE IN THE QUEUE WHAT. THANK
YOU I. AT THIS MOMENT WE WILL
AT THE- GO AHEAD AND BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE AND SEE
IF THERE'S ANY ANY COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. NO. AND
BUT SENATE QUARTERS WOULD YOU
LIKE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND- A VERY MUCH APPRECIATED-
THE TESTIMONY THAT WE DID
RECEIVE- ON BEHALF OF SB THREE
FOUR. AGREED TO A MODEST BUT
IMPORTANT CHANGE- TO. GET TO
CODIFY THIS PARTICULAR
PROVISION AND- I WOULD ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. OKAY WE HAVE A
MOTION BY L. R. VICE CHAIR OF
TO MOVE. SB. THREE EIGHT FOUR
FOUR AND- THIS IS A MOTION TO
PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON A PUBLIC SAFETY.
SB THREE EIGHT FOUR I TURN CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB
THREE EIGHT FOUR- THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST.
AMEND AND RE REFER TO COMMITTEE
ON PUBLIC SAFETY HER TADO. HI
JONES. COURTESY I PAN. PUT ON
HOLD ON CALL. WE WILL GO AHEAD
AND PLACE THIS BILL ON CALL AND
ALLOW OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TO. VOTE ON THIS
MEASURE. LATER ON. DO WE END UP
NEXT WE WILL BE HERE. FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE S. B. ONE ZERO SEVEN
BY SENATOR. WIENER PLEASE THESE
FEEL FREE TO BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM CHAIR- SB ONE OF SEVEN
MIGHT LOOK A LITTLE FAMILIAR-
BECAUSE WE HAVE BEEN PUSHING ON
THIS OR. THREE YEARS NOW TO
TRY TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
PEOPLE TO SIGN UP FOR
CALIBRATION CALIFORNIA-
CALIFORNIA MAKES IT WAY WAY TOO
HARD WHICH IS ONE OF WE WHICH
IS WHY. WE ARE- ONE OF THE
LOWEST STATES IN TERMS OF
CALFRESH UP TAKE THE PERCENTAGE
OF. ELIGIBLE PEOPLE WHO
ACTUALLY RECEIVE THE BENEFIT.
AND WE ARE DEAD LAST WHEN IT
COMES TO SENIORS. WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR CALFRESH YOU
ACTUALLY SIGN UP IT'S ACTUALLY-
THE CITY SHOULD BE EMBARRASSED.
BY HOW POORLY WE DOING SIGNING
PEOPLE UP FOR COVERAGE AND WE
HAVE TO DO BETTER. HI AND THIS
BILL WILL. ADDRESS TWO OF THE
SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS TO
CALIFORNIA'S. PUBLICATIONS ONE
IS TO FINALLY MANDATE THAT
EVERY SINGLE COUNTY IN
CALIFORNIA ALL FIFTY. ALLOW
PEOPLE TO SIGN UP FOR CALPERS
BY TELEPHONE- AND AGAIN IT'S
EMBARRASSING THAT WE NEED A
BILL TO TELL THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO TELL THE
COUNTIES. TODAY NEED TO LET
PEOPLE SIGN UP BY PHONE IT'S
VERY EMBARRASSING THAT WE NEED
A BILL TO DO THIS- BUT- A
SIGNIFICANT MAJORITY OF THE
COUNTIES DO NOT ALLOW PEOPLE.
TO SIGN UP BY PHONE. AND- WE'RE
MANDATING THAT THEY DO SO AND
SO IT'S A PRETTY SIMPLE
STRAIGHTFORWARD THING DENISON
TAKE A BILL. BUT ALAS HERE WE
ARE WITH THE BILL. ON. THE
OTHER- TO THE BILL HAS TO WITH
THE APP- AND IF EVER SEE THAT
CAN. APPLICATION IT IS EIGHTY
PAGES LONG BUT THAT ACTUALLY
UNDER US. ITS A VERY DENSE.
EIGHTEEN PAGES LONG I ACTUALLY
WENT THROUGH IT LAST NIGHT ON
MY IPAD- AFTER I. DID MY TAXES
ON SUNDAY- AND DOING MY TAXES
ON SUNDAY WAS MUCH EASIER THAN
IF I WERE TO FILL OUT- THOSE
EIGHTEEN PAGES AND WE EXPECT
FRAIL SENIORS. AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES- TO FILL OUT THAT
APPLICATION AND IS IT ANY
WONDER. THAT WE RANK LAST FIFTY
OUT F FIFTY STATES. IN TERMS
OF SENIORS WHO ACTUALLY SIGNED
UP FOR. A CALPERS TO THE BILL
WILL MANDATE A MUCH SHORTER
SIMPLIFIED. FORM FOR ANYONE
SIXTY AND OLDER LIVING WITH A
DISABILITY- AND WHEN YOU LOOK
AT SENIORS AND PEOPLE LIVING
WITH DISABILITIES THEY ARE MUCH
MORE LIKELY. TO ALREADY BE ON
SOME SORT OF GOVERNMENT BENEFIT
WHETHER IT BE SOCIAL SECURITY.
OR SSI OR OR WHAT HAVE YOU AND
SO. WE JUST DON'T NEED TO GET
AS MUCH INFORMATION. FROM THEM
TO BE CLEAR THESE ARE NOT THE
ONLY THINGS WE NEED TO DO- BUT
THESE ARE TWO SIGNIFICANT
BARRIERS THAT WE CAN REMOVE.
WITH THIS LEGISLATION AND SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR HONOR
I'VE- HONESTY ONE OF SEVEN.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY TO
TESTIFIED BY PHONE. OR JERRY
CALL SENIOR ADVOCATE FOR NURSE
CALIFORNIA ONE OF OUR SPONSORS.
AND LURE DIS GONZALEZ. WITH A
CALIFORNIA. OUT RESPECT. WITH
SAN. WHICH IS A BANK SENDING
COUNTY THANK YOU. MISTER
CORPORATE PLEASE POP TO BEGIN-
WHEN YOU'RE- SURE- GOOD
AFTERNOON PICTURE TACO MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE CHAIRED CALL
WITH YOUR CALIFORNIA WHAT'S UP
I THINK SENATOR WIENER HIS
LEADERSHIP ON A ONE OF THE BILL
THAT WILL BRING HUNGER AND
POVERTY BY RED TAPE AND POPEYE
THAT CALFRESH. I'D BE SEEN ECHO
THE CRY INCREASED ALL RIGHT
HIGH LEVEL HUNGER AND HARDSHIP
THE STATE THE MOST RECENT DATA
SHOW THAT NEARLY ONE IN FOUR
CALIFORNIA HOUSEHOLDS ARE
EXPERIENCING FOOD INSECURITY
THAT'S TWO AND A HALF TIMES
HIGHER THAN BEFORE THE CRISIS.
AND THE NUMBERS ARE EVEN MORE
STARK AMONG BLACK I'M NOT NEXT
HOUSEHOLDS WHICH RESPECTIVELY
EIGHT DOUBLE THE. THREE AND TWO
AND A HALF TIMES HIGHER THAN
THEIR WHITE CAL. CALFRESH DARMO
AFFECTED ANTI PRO. YET NEARLY
PERCENT OF L. A. CALIBER MISSED
OUT ON CALFRESH AT THE END
NOTED OUR STATE RANK LAST IN
THE NATION WHEN IT COMES TO A
ROLLING ELIGIBLE HOLDERS. OVER
AGE SIXTY. WE WANT WITH
KNOWLEDGE THE HARD. LEADERSHIP
AND AT THE COUNTY. HE HAD TO
SPEAK BETTER THAT ACTUALLY FOR
DAHLE BUT IN TO CLOSE THAT. GAP
WE NEED TO USE EVERY AVAILABLE
OUT IS SIMPLE BY ACT THAT'S FOR
HOW. AND THAT YOU ABOUT ONE OF
THE- AT THE CENTER NOTED THE
CURRENT CALPERS HAVE. IN THE
COMP. EIGHT DOCKING CAN BE.
UNDER OF ANY. AND FOR MANY
OLDER IT AND PEOPLE WITH.
DEVELOPMENT THAT THE BILL CAN
BE ON THE VERY ART. ALL MY
APPLICATIONS WORK WELL FOR SOME.
BUT MANY OLD ADULTS LACK RELY
INTERNET. OR DON'T YOU
COMFORTABLE JERRY PERSONAL AND
ONLINE TO BE RECORDED. FROM
STATE LIKE OUR BILL BECAUSE AND-
OLDER ADULTS WANT THE OPTION TO
COMPLETE THEM. APER AND WE CAN
DO THAT BY REMOVING THE-
QUESTIONS THAT DON'T. TO MANY
OLDER ADULT PEOPLE WITH. LIKE
TALK ABOUT INCOME. AND NOT.
OTHERS THAT HAVE BEEN THIS THE
USED AN ELDERLY. ISSUE A GREAT
IN PART. NOW REGARDING THE
TELEPHONIC. IS PRIOR TO THE
CALL THE CRISIS ONLY. ONE OF
FIFTY COUNTY CHOIR YEAH TO USE
TELEPHONIC SIGNATURE COMPETE.
DURING THE PANDEMIC BUT PRINT
GIVE ME A- TO GET YOUR YOU TO
WORK AROUND PROP THAT IT AND
MADE AVAILABLE. TEMPORARY
FEDERAL WAIVERS AND WEBER
SHOULD BE IN A B YOU. ON A
MONTH MONTH BASIS THEY WILL. AT
SOME POINT. SB ONE OF THE WOULD
THAT THE- WAIVERS. TELEPHONIC
SIGNATURE INTO BILLABLE ALL
CALL. NO MATTER WHERE THEY AND.
WE TO ACT NOW TO MAKE THESE
IMPROVEMENTS BERMAN. PART. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES WE CAN. JOHN GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS ONE OF THE
COMPONENTS I LOOK AT THAT
COFFEE SHOP WHICH IS. SCHEDULED
FOR A CALL BACK CENTER. I LIKE
TO THANK THE CHAIR IN. FAMILIES
CHILDREN AND MANY MANY TRUMP
FAMILY. OUR REPORT. OUR SECURE
IN OUR SERVER AREA BE SURE TO
ASK BUT WE WOULD HAVE CREATE SO
MUCH TO WITH THE COULD BE.
COMPETITION FOR BURNING PER AND
HELP THE NEED MORE MORE THAN IT.
ARE THANK EVER COULD. BECAUSE
WE A WHOLE TEAM OF BANK BAKER
TO HELPING IN ABOUT NEW
COVERAGE WE DO OUR BRIDGE A
THROUGHOUT THE COULD PROCESS
AND FOR THE WITH CLIENTS WITH
BERMAN CHALLENGES WITH THEIR.
WE HAVE A STRONG POINT WITH THE
HEALTH INSURANCE OF THE H. OR
RESPONSE FOR COMPLETING THE
ROOM PROCESS. THAT WILL HELP
CLIENTS. WITH THE EXTRA HELP
PROVIDE ACCOMPLISHMENTS. VERY
COMPLICATED I DON'T PEOPLE GET
CONFUSED BY THE LONG EPIC. IT
HARD TO CHANGE WHO SOMETIMES A
HARD TIME AND DONE AND WHY THEY
HAD TO UNPLUG SO MANY QUITE. I
WOULD. RIGHT BUT IT. NINE ELENA
POCKETBOOK BUT ONLY BUT FINALLY
WE WERE ABLE TO GET THEM AND
BROKE I WOULD LIKE. IT WILL BE
A LOT EACH YEAR INTO TIME IF
THE PAPER THANK YOU HAVE
TROUBLE LET. A LOT EVERYONE. AN
APPLICATION I PUT WE. WE HAVE
BEEN CONNECTED ENTER OVER THE
PHONE EXACTLY BUT HELPFUL. IT
SHOULD NEVER HAPPEN BUT- A
REALLY BIG I THINK YOU'RE GOING
TO. PLEASE MAKE A BIG
DIFFERENCE TO TRYING TO BE ABLE
TO PUT TO GO THAT PROCESS OVER
THE- EVEN AFTER THE COURT AND.
TO FIND. OUT EACH YEAR TO
COMPLETE REPORT AND CERTIFICATE.
THANK WE SUPPORT IT BE ONE OF
SEVEN IT WOULD BE TO CHANGES TO
LOOK AT EACH YEAR BUT
STRUGGLING TO A COPY BENEFITS
TO BUY THE FOOD THEY NEED.
THANK SURE A COMMITMENT MAY.
FORGET TIME. AND COULDN'T
INTERESTS. I WOULD LIKE AND I
WILL BE HAVE TRUMP ANY THAT YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I BOTH- AT
THIS MOMENT TIED LIKE TO OPEN
AT UP FOR UP COMMENT IN SUPPORT-
BUT BEFORE BUT BEFORE I DO THAT
SENATOR WIENER DO TO
SUPPLEMENTS THAT THE COMMITTEE
HAS OFFERED YES MY APOLOGIES OR
ACCEPTANCE. NO PROBLEM. THANK
YOU. I DO. I DON'T THINK THERE
WERE MOMENTS OKAY- OKAY. YES
CONGER CONGER OR THEIR MANAGER.
OF IT'S PAST. OKAY WELL WE ARE
MOVING FORWARD- WITH- A PUBLIC
COMMENT IN SUPPORT PLEASE LIMIT
YOUR COMMENT TO NAME
AFFILIATION A POSITION ONLY AND
WE WILL MOVE WITH- BEGINNING
HEARING ROOM FORTY TWO ZERO
THREE. C. NONE WE ARE. GOING
TO. MOVE ON THE TELEPHONE
PUBLIC LINE SEE NONE GOOD NO
ONE AND ROUTE. TWENTY FORTY.
OUR MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
PUT THE DIVISIONS WERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF S. B. ONE
ZERO SEVEN TO PROVIDE THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF S. B. ONE
ZERO SEVEN. YEAH LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SELL
SUPPORT FOR S. B. ONE OH SEVEN.
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO NOW
AGAIN TO SHOW SUPPORT. PRESS
ONE AND THEN THERE ARE NOW. AND
WE HAVE ABOUT TWENTY Q. AND TE
Q. OKAY PINKWATER RAIDER PLEASE.
BOB OPEN UP THE LINES AND CALL
THE SUPPORT WHEN HIS SUPPORT
WOULD DISS INDIVIDUALLY AND
ONCE AGAIN I JUST WANT TO
REITERATE PLEASE LIMIT YOUR
COMMENT TO THE NAME I.
ORGANIZATION A POSITION ON THE
BILL. WELFARE LINE THIRTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND THEN-
TRACKERS TO RESPONSES WESTERN
CENTER NONPARTISAN SUPPORT.
MAXIMO CAROLINE FIFTY TWO
PLEASE GLAD. KELLY BEING WITH
HEALTH NET AND CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AND WELLNESS SERVING
ALMOST TWO MILLION THAT ACCOUNT
NUMBERS IN CALIFORNIA ENQUIRE
AT AT THE ONE OH SEVEN THANK
YOU. MAXIMO TIMELINE THIRTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADELINE COOPER FROM
THE OPEN MARKET MORE ON BEHALF
OF MARIN COUNTY AND CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY IN SUPPORT. MAXIMO
CAROLINE THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOUR MEMBERS KATHY
MUSCLE BUT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB ONE SEVEN.
MAXIMO CAROLINE THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS TRIPLICATE OR ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
MARKET CORPORATION BETTER KNOWN
AS THE SF IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MAXIMO CAROLINE TWELVE PLEASE
BUT I HAD. KELLY BROOKS ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION HERE IN
SUPPORT. MAXIMAL TO LINE THIRTY
FOUR LEAVES BUT I HAD. BEEN
AROUND ON BEHALF OF ROUTE TO
CHANGE ALSO IN SUPPORT. MAXIMO
TIME SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LIBBY CENTERS ON BEHALF OF THE
FBI YOU CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
MAXIMO TO LINE FIFTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. EITHER COME INTO ONE
ON EHALF OF ALAMEDA COUNTY
COMMUNITY FOOD BANK IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB ONE HUNDRED. NEXT
SOME OF TO LINE FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CRACKLE OF HER FROM A KILLER
HELP IN STRONG SUPPORT. MAXIMO
TRYING TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. PACK FROM THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE
OF SEVEN THANK YOU. MAXIMO TO
LINE FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BUT THE SHORTED DELMAR COUNTY
EMERGENCY FOOD SECURITY TASK
FORCE IN SUPPORT. MAXIMO CLIENT
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NO
SHIRKA FOLK VOLUNTEER POLICY
ADVISER FOR A RP. IN STRONG
SUPPORT. MAXIMO KLEIN FIFTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DR DIANA
SHAVER PRESIDENT OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION THE LARGEST COUNTY
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE ORGANIZATION AND
SUPPORT SB ONE OF SEVEN. THANK
YOU. MAXIMO TRYING TWENTY FOUR
CLEVELAND HAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
DEREK POCO ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES REGIONAL FOOD BANK IN
STRONG SUPPORT SB ONE OF.
MAXIMO TIME THIRTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON HEIDI
MCHUGH IT REPRESENTING FOOD FOR
PEOPLE THE STATE BANK FOR
HUMBOLDT COUNTY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB ONE OH SEVEN.
MAXIMO TIME THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHENEY
MARC AND ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. MAXIMO TRYING FIFTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ANDERSON
ON BEHALF OF THE ARK AND UNITED
CEREBRAL PALSY CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATION INCOME OR- MAXTOR
OF TEN NINE FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI EVERYBODY IS FROM
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION OF OUR SUPPORT SB
ONE OF SEVEN. SOME OF THE LINE
FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GROUP PROJECTED OPEN HEART
KITCHEN LIVERMORE CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. SOME OF TIME THIRTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HEY JUSTIN
GARRETT CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES FOR.
MAXIM OF KILL AND TWENTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. FOSTER WROTE ON
BEHALF OF THE LONG BEACH LINE
STRUCTURED FINANCE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. IN MAXIMO TO LINE
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
REMEMBER WHEN WITH THE GOVERNOR
AND TRIBAL LANDS COMMUNITY
COUNCIL AS WELL AS THE .ORG
YOUR HONOR AND SUPPORT. AND
ONCE AGAIN TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR
S. B. ONE OH SEVEN PRESS THE
WIND AND THERE ARE NOW AGAIN HE
SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB ONE OH
SEVEN PRESS ONE AND THEN THERE
ARE NOW. I HAVE ABOUT TWO MORE
IN THE QUEUE WILL GO TO LINE
FORTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU DAVID WITH THE SAN
FRANCISCO MARIN FOOD BANK IN
STRONG SUPPORT. AND JUST ONE
MOMENT WELL MOVE TO LINE FIFTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
RESTAURANT THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION
HERE IN COURT. AND AT THIS TIME
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE. THANK YOU MODERATOR AT
THIS MOMENT WE WILL MOVE TO
PUBLIC COMMENT IN OPPOSITION
OF. S. B. ONE ZERO SEVEN. BOB
DO WE HAVE ANY OPPOSITION FORTY
TWO OR THREE C. NINE TWENTY
FORTY SEEN NONE. ARE WE WILL
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES- IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. ONE ZERO
SEVEN VIA TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE. I JUST ONCE AGAIN WANT
TO REMIND IF YOU CAN LIMIT YOUR
NAME AND THAT LIMIT TESTIMONY
TO NAME. AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL MODERATOR
PLEASE OP PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
READY JUST FINE OPPOSITION TO
S. B. ONE ZERO SEVEN. SURE
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO UPHOLD S. B. ONE OH
SEVEN PRESS ONE THEN THERE ARE
NOW AGAIN TO A POEM. S. B. ONE
OH SEVEN PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
NOW. AND WE HAVE NO ONE IN THE
QUEUE. THANK YOU MODERATOR- AT
THIS MOMENT- I WILL DRINK
MOTIONS THE COMMENTS BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS. ON THIS
BILL. SEEN NONE OKAY- CENTER
WINNER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. DO WE
HAVE A MOTION ON SB ONE ZERO
SEVEN WHO WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR CORTES WHO TO- TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE RE REFER TO THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
A SECRETARY KING PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. S. B. ONE OH SEVEN
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
APARTADO. HI FOR TITLE II JONES
JONES HI COURTESY COURTESY I
PAN. THANK YOU WE WILL AT THIS
MOMENT PLACE THE BILL ON CALL
FOR. UP NEXT WE HAVE AGENDA
ITEM NUMBER TWO S. B. TWO THREE
FOUR- THE SENATOR WINNER PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO BEGIN WHEN YOU ARE
READY AND I JUST WANT TO.
PROVIDE THIS DOES HAVE QUITE
DOES THIS BILL HAD BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. IT FOR. SURE ALL RIGHT
THIS BILL HAS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT FOR IT THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR INTENDED COMMITTEE FOR
WORKING WITH US ON THIS BILL.
OUR COLLEAGUES ARE SENATE BILL
TWO THIRTY FOUR- WILL ADDRESS A
VERY SIGNIFICANT ISSUE THAT WE
HAVE- SPECIFICALLY THE LACK OF
HOUSING FOR- REMOTE ARE MOST AT
RISK TRANSITION AGE YOUTH
SPECIFICALLY YOUTH. EXITING
HOMELESSNESS EXITING- FOSTER
CARE- AND EXITING THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM I WILL DO SO BY
CREATING A ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR FORGIVABLE LOAN FUNDS-
TO ACQUIRE A- OR- CONSTRUCT-
HOUSING- FOR THESE AT RISK
YOUTH- THE NUMBERS ARE VERY
STARK- IN TERMS OF THE RATE OF
HOMELESSNESS AMONG OUR AT RISK
YOUTH- PARTICULARLY THOSE-
EXITING FOSTER CARE INCLUDING
THE EXTENDED FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM. AND THOSE EXITING THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. VERY
HIGH RATES OF HOMELESSNESS FIVE
AND THAT IS PARTICULARLY TRUE
FOR OUR USE- WHO OF COLOUR AND
OUR LGBTQ- YOUTH IMPACT OF
NEARLY HALF OF. HOMELESS YOUTH
IDENTIFY AS LGBTQ. WE KNOW THAT
MOST CALIFORNIA COUNTIES DO NOT
HAVE YOU SPECIFIC HOMELESS
PROGRAMS AND SO THE YOU TEND TO
GET LUMPED IN WITH THE ADULTS
WHICH MEANS. THEY OFTEN SIMPLY
DON'T ACCESS. BROWN'S CAL HAS
OF DIS- ARE PRESENTED OF ANY
HOME YOUTH AND THE ONS.
HOMELESS USE AND FRANK OF THE
STATE HAS NOT DONE ENOUGH WE'VE
BEEN DOING MORE. IN RECENT
YEARS BUT NOT NOUGH SO AS TO
TWO THIRTY FOUR WAY ALLOCATE A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO
CREATE HOUSING SPECIFICALLY.
FOR THIS DEMOGRAPHIC ABOUT HALF
OF WHICH WILL BE DEDICATED TO
YOU THE EXITING THE FOSTER
YOUTH SYSTEM. THE BILL OUTLINES
ARE HELD A FUNDING WILL BE
ADMINISTERED- AND THE LENGTH OF
THE- LOANS FOR THESE ARE HELP
FOR THE HOUSING AND AS LONG AS
A HOUSING REMAINS USED IN THIS
WAY TO HOUSE THESE OUT RISK
TRANSITION DO. ALONE- DOES NOT
HAVE TO BE. REPAID THIS IS-
SOMETHING THAT IS PARTICULARLY-
IMPORTANT RIGHT NOW DURING CO
THE WE'RE PEOPLE ARE EVEN MORE
HOUSING UNSTABLE THE NORMAL-
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR ON A
VOTE. WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL OR DAVID
BAKER- YOUNG PERSON WITH THE
YMCA OF SAN DIEGO.AND KRISTEN
POWER WITH THE ALLIANCE FOR
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS WHICH IS ONE
OF OUR SPONSORS- AND- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I'M SURE. THANK YOU
WE WILL NOT OPEN AT A TO AND
THIS IS IN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
LEADER. IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION WILL BE LIMITED TO
THREE MINUTES EACH ALL OTHERS
WISHING TO TESTIFY DURING
PUBLIC COMMENT MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THE NAME
AFFILIATION A POSITION ON THE
MEASURES. AND WE WILL GO AHEAD
AND BEGIN WITH- WHAT IS NUMBER
ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES WE CAN. EXCELLENT
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU ALL FOR HOLDING SPACE FOR
THIS HEARING AND ALSO FOR ALL
OF YOUR LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS TO
HELP OUR YOUTH AND YOUNG
ADULTS- MY NAME IS DAVID BAKER
I AM A HOUSING PROGRAM DIRECTOR
FOR LANSING ASSEMBLY SERVICES
DOWN IN KENDALL COUNTY- I'M
HERE IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO TO
EXPLORE AND TO LEND MY STORY AS
AN EXAMPLE OF HOW VITAL THE
NECESSARY TRANSITIONAL LIVING
PROGRAMS AREN'T FOR UNDERSERVED
AND VULNERABLE YOUNG PEOPLE-
WITH RESPECT TO TIME I'LL BE
BRIEF BUT- I COME FROM A
BACKGROUND OF HOMELESSNESS AND
INTERGENERATIONAL POVERTY.
WHICH MEANS THAT MY
GRANDMOTHER'S POVERTY AND MY
MOTHER'S PROPERTY WHICH IN TURN
BECAME MY OWN- HOUSING AND
FINANCIAL SECURITY LOOMED FOR
MY HOUSEHOLD AND BY SIXTEEN- I
UNDERSTOOD THAT WE JUST DIDN'T
HAVE ENOUGH RESOURCES TO MEET
MY BASIC NEEDS SO INSTEAD OF
BEING A BURDEN ON MY ALREADY
STRUGGLING MOTHER AND FAMILY
AND CHOSE TO RUN AWAY- I DIDN'T
KNOW WHERE I WAS HEADED BUT I
KNEW THAT ANYWHERE WAS BETTER
THAN. THE BOTTOM- AND MY ALMOST
EXPERIENCE WASN'T MUCH
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT I
EXPERIENCED GROWING UP BY
SCRAPED BY WILL COUCHSURFING
SHELTERS SORT OF LIVING OUT OF
A SUITCASE WHEREVER I CAN FIT-
AND IT WASN'T UNTIL I WAS
TWENTY ONE AND THAT I WAS- I
FOUND A POSSIBLE HOUSING
SOLUTION CALLED A TRANSITIONAL
LIVING PROGRAM- AND I REMEMBER
THE PROGRAM ORIENTATION BEING
PACKED WITH NO OPEN CHAIR SO I
STOOD IN THE BACK AND I.
LISTENED TO THIS AMAZING
OPPORTUNITY BOB BELIEVING
THERE'S NO LATE COULD BE TRUE-
INITIALLY SENTIMENT THAT COMMON
AMONGST YOUNG PEOPLE FROM
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES BUT
THANKFULLY IT ALL LESS TRUE I
WAS ACCEPTED INTO THE
TRANSITIONAL LIVING PROGRAM AND
THAT WAS THE TURNING POINT FOR
ME- FOR THE FIRST TIME I HAD
BEEN GIVEN A STABLE FOUNDATION
ON WHICH TO BUILD MY SUCCESS
AND A SUPPORT SYSTEM THAT WAS
NOT BROKEN OR DAMAGED- I WAS
ABLE TO FINISH MY HIGHER
EDUCATION. AND BECOME THE FIRST
TO GRADUATE FROM ABOUTMICHAEL
BYE AND I. BUILT A BUSINESS
THAT OPERATES ON WEEK AND ALLOW
YOUNG PEOPLE TO THE THEIR OWN.
I BUILT A CAREER FOR- HELPING.
LIKE ME. WHERE I SHE- I OVERSEE
ENTIRE NETWORK OF HOUSE
ADVOCATES AND SOCIAL WORKERS
AND OUR ONLY JOB. IS TO HOUSE
OUR PEOPLE THANK. HOUSE I CAN
SAY WE HAVE. THIS AFFECTED
LEGAL SYSTEM OF CARE TO WRAP
AROUND ARE. AND CATER TO THEIR
SPECIFIC NEEDS AND- THE ONLY
MISSING PIECE ARE THE ACTUAL
HOUSING UNITS TO PLACE THEM IN-
TO BRING IT FULL CIRCLE. I THE
PERSON I AM TODAY CAME FROM A
TRANSITIONAL LIVING PROGRAM. A
YOUNG PERSON OF COLOR HAS
HURDLED THE SYSTEMIC BARRIERS
TO SUCCESS THAT HAVE.
RESTRICTED US FOR GENERATIONS
BECAUSE I WAS GIVEN A SECOND
LOOK AND THE SAFE PLACE TO
GROW- I'M HERE TODAY TO ASK YOU
TO HELP YOUNG PEOPLE LIKE ME-
THERE ARE SO MANY OF US THAT
ARE NEEDED THESE PROGRAMS BUT
DON'T HAVE THE ACCESS BECAUSE-
THE EXISTING INVESTMENT AND
YOU. SPECIFIC HOUSING IS. SO
SMALL COMPARED TO THE NEED-
HAVING. FUNDS TO STRUCTURE
HOUSING SPECIFICALLY FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE TELL THE YOUNG PERSON
LIKE ME. WE ARE NOT DEFINED BY
THEIR FAMILIES OR THEIR LIFE
CIRCUMSTANCES. IT TELL THE
YOUNG PERSON THAT THEIR
POTENTIAL AND THEIR DREAMS
MATTER. AND SHOULD BE GIVEN THE
CHANCE TO FLOURISH- I JUST.
NOTICED COMMITTEE KNOWS THIS
BUT INVESTING IN US- YOUNG
PEOPLE. IS A DIRECT INVESTMENT
IN THE FUTURE- AND A DIRECT
INVESTMENT. AND THE FUTURE OF
OUR GREAT STATE AND I. B. ON
SEP THANK YOU ALL FOR COMING.
OUT AND I'M HERE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU DAVE OUR
WILL MOVE ON TO WHAT NUMBER
TWO. PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU ARE
READY LOOKED AT HER TADO. THANK
YOU SENATOR CATHERINE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. SHOULD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
OF SB THREE THIRTY FOR THE
SUPPORT ACT FOR OUR STATE AT
RISK YOUTH I'M KRISTIN POWER
VICE PRESIDENT POLICY AND
ADVOCACY FOR THE ALLIANCE FOR
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS A CO SPONSOR
OF THE BILL ALONG WITH PARTNERS
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YOUTH.
CHILDREN NOW GRAYSON. AND CHILD
POVERTY CALIFORNIA. THE PRIMARY
PURPOSE OF THE OF FOSTER CARE
PROGRAM IS TO PREPARE YOU FOR
THEIR SUCCESSFUL TRANSITION
INTO ADULTHOOD. CALIFORNIA IS
EXTREMELY COMPETITIVE HOUSING
MARKET HAS LED TO HOUSING
INSTABILITY AND HOMELESSNESS
VALUES AN EXTENDED FOSTER CARE.
WE KNOW THAT YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
EAGER TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
PROGRAM SUCH AS THE
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING PROGRAM
NOT MINOR DEPENDENTS ARE T. H.
P. AND NP GIVEN THE WAITLISTED
EXCEPT ACROSS OUR STATE. AND
YOU JUST HEARD THAT EXPLAINS
HOW IMPORTANT THOSE PROGRAMS
ARE SUCCESSFUL. TRANSITION TO
ADOPT THAT. I TWO THIRTY FOR
IT'S WAY TO CONCRETE THE ONE
BEST YOU. BY DEDICATING FOR
FACT THAT. IT IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TO INVEST INCREASE
HOUSING AVAILABILITY TO ENSURE
THAT ALL WHO WANT TO
PARTICIPATE IN EXTENDED FOSTER
CARE CAN TAKE FULL ADVANTAGE OF
THE PROGRAM. AND UNACCOMPANIED
HOMELESS YOUTH RESPECTFULLY AND
BASICALLY HAVE TO PREVENT THE
HEIGHTENED RISK THEY'RE
ENTERING HOMELESSNESS. WE MUST.
HI FROM YOUR- DECRYING A
HOMELESSNESS. AT TWO THIRTY
FOUR RECOGNIZE THE HOME
ACCORDING AND PLANNING THANK
YOU WAS PASSED BY THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD ADDRESSING
YOUTH EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
CREATING MORE UNIFORMITY AROUND
THESE AFFECT. AN ATHLETE TO
THIRTY FOUR AND GOT THEM BOTH
THE FUTURE WAS NINETEEN I THINK
THE CLAMPING HOMELESSNESS
INTERSTATE INFRASTRUCTURE BY
INCENTIVIZING SHOVEL READY
PROJECTS BY REMOVING FINANCIAL
BARRIERS TO CONSTRUCTION WHICH
WILL ADDRESS BUT THE CRITICAL
THING HOUSING CRISIS AND
CONSISTENT HOUSING NEEDS
RELATED TO THE CURB THE BANKING
PANDEMIC AVAILABLE. TRANSIT
NEEDS TO. TWENTY APPRECIATE
CENTER WIENER SAID. IT ABOUT
THINGS AND STABLE HOUSING YOU I
RESPECTFULLY YOUR ITEM THE
MEASURE. THANK YOU BOTH FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY WE WILL BE
MOVING FORWARD- WITH PUBLIC
COMMENT SUPPORT. ARE SEEN ON IN
ROOM FORTY TWO ZERO THREE WILL
BE NOT TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
SEEN NONE. WE WILL MOVE ON TO
OUR TELEPHONE PUBLIC COMMENT
LINE. ARE THOSE OF WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO THE WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE AS A
REMINDER TO THOSE WHO ARE
WAITING ON THE PHONE PLEASE
LIMIT YOUR TESTIMONY TO NAME
AFFILIATION AND YOUR POSITION
ON THE BILL A MODERATOR PLEASE
PUMP INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
THREE FOUR. AND PROVIDE THE
TOTAL NUMBER PLEASE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR
AT THE- REPORTER PRESS ONE THAN
THEIR OWN NOW AGAIN TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR S. B. TWO THREE
FOUR PRESS ONE THEN ZERO NOW.
ME DO YOU HAVE ABOUT EIGHT AND
LIKE YOU. THANK YOU MODEL
NUMBER. THANK YOU MODERATE
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES AND CALL
THE SUPPORT MRS INDIVIDUALLY.
SHARE BOTH SARAH NUMBER FORTY
SEVEN CLEVELAND. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR THIS IS JACKIE TO
CLONE LONGHAND MEMBERS LIKE
MANY TO JACKIE TO COME ALONG
WITH THEM BECAUSE THEY HAVE A
GREAT FINANCIAL POWER IN
CALIFORNIA WE ARE PROUD TO BE
CO SPONSORS ALONGSIDE P. P. Y.
EIGHT CHILDREN NOW IN THE LINE
FOR CHILDREN'S RIGHT. HANDER
TONIGHT BUT. GET A MUCH. MAXIM
OF CLIENT SIX THREE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM ABOUT THAT
THE DORIS STRAND FOR BUT THE
CAL SCHOOL ASSOCIATION WE'RE
HERE IN SUPPORT. THANKS SO MUCH
HELLO I AM EIGHT PRE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON KIM REPRESENTING
MACAU COALITION FOR YOUTH
FINANCIAL NOW BECAUSE BONTA ON
THE BELL IN SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSAL THANK YOU WIENER.
MAXIMO TRYING TO SIX WE'VE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS A HOMELAND I
AM REPRESENTING LARKIN STREET
YOUTH SERVICES WHICH IS SAN
FRANCISCO'S LARGEST NONPROFIT
PROVIDERS OF HAVING INTERNET
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AND I
WANT TO OFFER M STRONG
SUPPORTER CAN BE PROSECUTED-
CHIU SENATOR WIENER. THANK YOU.
MAXIMO TELLING TWENTY CRITICAL.
FROM APRIL AT OUR IN SUPPORT OF
ATHLETES PEOPLE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MAXIMO FIFTY GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M SURE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JAN
OUTSIDE. HOCKLEY COUNTY HEALTH
DIRECTORS WHICH IS SUPPORT S.
B. DO YOU FOUR THANK YOU. MAXIM
OF TRYING TWENTY THREE I HAD.
FIVE MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBER SHERILYN ADAMS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF LARKIN STREET YUTH
SERVICES IN SAN FRANCISCO- IT
DRUNK THE PART OF SB TWO THREE
FOUR AND GRATITUDE HER SENATOR
WIENER THANK YOU. IN MAXIMO
TIMELINE TWENTY NINE CLEVELAND
HAD. MY NAME IS ATTICA YAZDI
I'M A PERSON WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCE IN A CLIENT OF
LARKIN STREET YOUTH SERVICES I
URGE OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR SB
TWO THREE FOUR AND THANK YOU-
SCOTT. AND AS A REMINDER TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR S. B. TWO
THREE FOUR PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
NOW AGAIN TO SHOW SUPPORT PRESS
LONDON ZERO NOW. AND WE HAVE NO
ONE IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU MODERATOR- HAVEN'T
HEARD FROM ALL SUPPORTERS
PEOPLE NOW FOLLOWS THE SAME
PROCESS TO HEAR FROM ANY
OPPOSITION- AND WE WILL BEGIN
WITH ANY PUBLIC COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. TWO THREE
FOUR IN ROOM FORTY. TWO ZERO
THREE C. NINE. ARE WE WILL
CHECK APPROVED TWENTY FORTY SEE
NON- WE WILL GO AHEAD AND MOVE
TO THE TELEPHONE PUBLIC COMMENT
LINE. MODERATOR KEY PLEASE PUMP
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OF SB TWO THREE
FOUR APART THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
PEOPLE EACH DESPITE OPPOSITION.
SURE LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO UPHOLD S. B. TWO
THREE FOUR PRESS THE ONE THAN
THERE ARE NOW AGAIN TO UPHOLD
S. B. TWO THREE FOUR PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO NOW. M. I DO NOT KILL
ANYONE IN THE QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU MODERATOR- AT
THIS MOMENT TO BRING IT BACK TO
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON THIS
MEASURE. NO COMMENTS NO
QUESTIONS OKAY SENATOR WIENER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THE
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. MOVE
THE BILL. THANK YOU WE HAVE A
MOTION BY CENTER CORTES HEAT ON
SB TWO THREE FOR THE MOTION IS-
TO PROSPER FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON HOUSING. OUR
SECRETARY CAN PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. S. S. B. TWO THREE FOR
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMITTEE ON
HOUSING HER TADO. I FOR TITLE
II JONES. JONES I CORTESE I.
CORTESE ALIVE I PAN. OKAY WE
WILL PUT THIS BILL ON CALL
THANK YOU SENATOR WIENER. AND
WE ARE GOING TO BE MOVING A
LITTLE BIT BACK UP TO BE A
GENTLE TO AGENDA ITEM NUMBER
THREE. S. B. TWO FIVE EIGHT
FIVE SENATOR LAYER. WELCOME M.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS IT'S- MY PLEASURE
TO PRESENT- SENATE BILL TWO
FIFTY EIGHT IT SEEKS TO
INCREASE PARTICIPATION IN
CALIFORNIA'S. AGENCIES ON AGING
BY TARGETING SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES AND PROGRAMS TOWARD
HIV POSITIVE OLDER ADULTS
SPECIFICALLY IT WILL UPDATE
CALIFORNIA'S STATED DEFINITION
OF GREATER SOCIAL NEED TO
INCLUDE CULTURAL OR SOCIAL
ISOLATION CAUSED BY HIV STATUS.
FOR ME THIS COMBINES TWO PLACES
I WAS IN THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES
OF ONE WAS IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
HIV EPIDEMIC WHERE ARE WAS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF A
NONPROFIT. THAT DEALT WITH HIV
SERVICES LOCALLY AND WHERE WE
ONLY HOPED THAT PEOPLE WOULD
LIVE TO OLD AGE WITH A CHARGE
SHE WASN'T HAPPENING AT THE
TIME AND NOW 50% OF THE PEOPLE
THAT HAVE HIV IN CALIFORNIA OR
OVER THE AGE OF FIFTY EXACTLY
WHAT WE HAD HOPED FOR IS
HAPPENING PEOPLE ARE AGING. OUT
OF WITH HIV SECONDLY ARE WAS
CHAIR FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS OF
THE LOCAL AREA AGENCY ON AGING.
AND SANTA CRUZ NATURALLY DID
THINGS IN THE REVERSE OF
EVERYWHERE ELSE BECAUSE
EVERYWHERE ELSE THE ELECTED
OFFICIALS WERE THE CHAIR AND
THE BOARD OF THE AREA AGENCY ON
AGING AND THE SENIORS WERE
ADVISORY IN SANTA CRUZ THE
SENIORS WERE THE ONES THAT WERE
IN CHARGE IN THE ELECTED
OFFICIALS WERE THE ONES THAT
WERE ADVISORY. AND SO I WAS
CHAIR OF THE ADVISORY COUNCIL
WHICH REALLY ADVISED ON THE
DIRECTION OF SERVICES TO
SENIORS. IN OUR COMMUNITY. AND
SO ON NOW THIS WOULD ADDRESS.
THAT ISSUE OF PRIORITIZING. OF
FOR THE GREATEST SOCIAL NEED.
OF PEOPLE WITH HIV AND RIGHT
NOW WHAT THAT MEANS IS THAT AND
SERVICES WITH THE AREA AGENCY
ON AGING THERE'S A PRIORITY FOR
OUT REACH. TO SPECIAL
POPULATIONS. NEED OUR EXIST LAW
DEFINES GREATNESS SOCIAL NAY.
TO MEET THE NEEDS IS BECAUSE BY
NO ACTON FACTORS INCLUDING
PHYSICAL AND MENTAL
DISABILITIES THAT MAY BE COSTA
RELATED. TO ANY OF A NUMBER OF
FACTORS. AND SO THAT WOULD ADD
THIS TO THAT CATEGORY AND
PRIORITIZE SERVICES SO- IT
WOULD. IT WOULD REALLY EASE THE
BURDEN OF CONNECTING OUR MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS TO
SUPPORT OF AGING ERVICES AND
PROGRAMS SO THAT WE CAN ENSURE
THAT OLDER ADULTS WILL AGE IN
PLACE WITH DIGNITY AS WE DO FOR
MANY POPULATIONS AND MANY
CATEGORIES. S. B. TWO FIFTY
EIGHT IS SPONSORED BY QUALITY
CALIFORNIA THE LOS ANGELES LGBT
CENTER STAGE AND IT'S PROJECT
LOS ANGELES HELP IT'S WIDELY
SUPPORTED. BY MANY
ORGANIZATIONS AGING
ORGANIZATIONS OF THE NAPA
SOLANO AREA AGENCY ON AGING
ISN'T SUPPORT HIV ADVOCATES AND
THE INSURANCE COMMISSIONER AS
WELL AS LGBT GROUPS UP AND DOWN%
THE STATE. HURT TODAY ARE TO
TESTIFY BRIEFLY IN SUPPORT OR
TAMMY MARTIN OF THE QUALITY
CALIFORNIA ENTERS ANDERSON OF A
GROUP KNOWN AS LET'S KICK ****
AIDS I WAS HOPING FOR AN
ACRONYM BUT THAT'S WHAT I GOT.
SO THOSE ARE THE TWO WITNESSES
SAID AND WHEN WE'RE ALL DONE
MADAM CHAIR- I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPHONE.
THANK YOU CENTER TODAY- EIGHT-
IT TITLE- WE ARE GOING TO OPEN
IT UP AT THIS MOMENT TO
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
OPPOSITION LEADER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION WILL BE
LIMITED TO THREE MINUTES EACH-
AND WE'LL BEGIN WITH I OF.
WITNESS NUMBER ONE. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS COUNTY MARTIN
ON BEHALF OF EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA FOR THE NATION'S
LARGEST STATEWIDE LGBTQ PLUS
CIVIL RIGHTS ORGANIZATION AND A
PROUD CO SPONSOR OF THIS BILL.
WE THANK SENATOR LYRICS FOR
CAMPAIGNING THIS BILL WHICH
WILL REALLY DEMONSTRATE
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT FOR OLDER
ADULTS. THE CIVIC WE OLDER
PEOPLE LIVING WITH HIV- I'VE
DESCRIBED BY DESIGNATING THEM
AFTER POPULATION OF GREATER
SOCIAL MEDIA AND THE TECHNICIAN
ENSURES THAT THE AREA AGENCIES
ON AGING. ARE ACTIVELY REACHING
OUT TO THE POPULATION SO THAT
THEY KNOW WHAT SERVICES AND
SUPPORT EXIST THE SAME AS THEY
DO NOW FOR POPULATIONS THAT ARE
ALREADY DESIGNATED. POPPING
THEM ALL STAY HEALTHY AND LIVE
WITH DIGNITY. AND DATA AND
EXPERIENCE SHOW US WHY THIS
BILL IS REALLY NEEDED. AND I'VE
AUTHORED POINTED OUT OVER 50%
OF CALIFORNIANS RIGHT NOW ARE
LIVING- OF CALIFORNIANS WERE
LIVING WITH HIV ARE AGE FIFTY
OR OLDER THANK YOU ADVANCEMENT
IN TREATMENT. AT THE SAME TIME
THOUGH THE POPULATION FACES
BARRIERS TO SUCCESSFUL AGING
THAT REFLECT THEIR LACK OF
ACCESS TO SERVICES A FACED
PRONOUNCED HOW. NEEDS AND MUCH
HIGHER RATES OF DEPRESSION DUE
TO STIGMA ISOLATION AND
LONELINESS AND GIVEN THAT
LIMITED SOCIAL SUPPORT THEY DO
OFTEN LOOK TO GOVERNMENT AND
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES. BUT
STILL REPORT BARRIERS AND A
LACK OF COMPETENT KERR EVEN IN
URBAN AREAS LET ALONE IN
SMALLER CITIES AND RURAL AREAS.
I THINK YOU GET THE EIGHT
CONTINUE THE PROGRESS THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS MADE TOWARD
RECOGNIZING THE NEEDS OF PEOPLE
LIVING WITH HIV AND AIDS IN
LINE WITH THE PROGRESS THE
LEGISLATURE OVERALL HIS NEED.
TO UPDATE THE LAW TO REFLECT
SCIENCE AND NOT STIGMA THE
COSPONSORED AND OUR EXTENSIVE
NETWORK OF COMMUNITY ADVOCATES
AND SERVICE PROVIDERS. STAND
READY TO ASSIST WITH
IMPLEMENTATION AND WE
RESPECTFULLY. URGE YOUR SUPPORT
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND-
WILL BE MOVING A THIS MOMENT-
WITH WHAT MR TWO PLEASE BEGIN
WHEN YOUR READY. I I'M DOES
THAT. ON BEHALF OF KICKED OUT
OF A SERVER. THAT THE AKRON.
CHEVROLET WAS LOOKING FOR- WE
ARE BASED IN SAN FRANCISCO ARE
THOSE DAY FOUNDED BY FORMER
ABOUT OVER A LIVING LAW. WITH
HIV I'M NOT GOING TO GIVE YOU
THE- YOUR CURRENT VALUES. I
THOUGHT AND MY- AND- THE PEOPLE
THAT SERVE. WHICH IS WHY
LARGELY HOPE THAT ONE OF BEING
FORGOT ABOUT. IT FEELS LIKE
THEY WERE WAS LITTLE DOT PASSED
A AND THAT BECAUSE OF EIGHT YOU
WITH THIS WE ARE VERGE OF IN
DAHLE MOST OF THEM. WE'VE BEEN
GOTTEN THE PRODUCT. AND THE
CLEANING THAT WE LIVE AT. AND I
WAS. HAVING ACCESS A MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES. TO BE ONE OF
THE MOST OF THE CHALLENGE I CAN
HAVE- WE CAN'T BUY ME- I'M- WHY
LIVE WITH OUT OF DATE YEAH. OR
LIGHT. SO HOW TO TREAT OTHERS
NO I SERVE BECAUSE NEED. YOU'RE
VERY. ALSO I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THE- IT'S
NOT ABOUT NUMBER MATCH THAT
WITH H. I WOULD POP ITS BUDGET
EIGHTY THREE. I'M NOW SIXTY. I
WAS TO A- SO POVERTY IS ISSUE
WHERE HAS LIVED IN THE COLD.
FROM. THE MEDICATION BUT I TOOK
THE COLLEGE LIFE- ABILITIES.
YOUR OPERATING BONE DENSITY. WE
ALSO FROM FROM SHOCK THOSE
ISSUES AS DEPRESSION AND
ANXIETY SLEEP DISORDERS AND THE
END THEY WILL REAL ISSUE. I SAW
WHICH IS I CAN'T STRESS. I IT
EVERY DAY LONG TERM SURVIVAL
AND OLDER ADULTS HOW FEEL AT
ODDS. AND WE HAVE BOY. S. SO S.
B. TWO FIFTY WHILE- I BE AWAY
OF. ALLOW THAT TO ACCESS. HELP
IS ONE OF MANY OF MY COHORT
OVER THE YEARS WHO I'M ABOUT
THAT. I DON'T WANT TO SEE THAT
EVER HAPPENING. SHABIR THIS MY
MEDINA SUPPORT FROM BILL TWENTY
FIVE. TWO FIFTY. BOUGHT A
LETTER US BE A PART OF THE ALL
OF WILL THE AT. BILDERBERG BACK.
WELL POPULATION GREATEST PART
BY MY TUMBLING IS BLOCK FOR
TIME DOING AND- THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THE TO YOU
BOTH FOR YOUR TODAY. AT THIS
MOMENT WE WILL OPEN IT UP TO
PUBLIC COMMENT AND SUPPORT WILL
BEGIN WITH ROOM FORTY TWO ZERO
THREE. SEEING NONE ROOM TWENTY
FORTY T. NINE- WE WILL MOVE ON
TO AT THE TELEPHONE UP A PUBLIC
COMMENT LINE A MODERATOR PLEASE
PUMP THE DIVISION'S WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO
FIVE EIGHT AND PROVIDE AID THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR S. B. TWO FIVE
EIGHT PRESS LONDON ZERO NOW.
AGAIN TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR S. B.
TWO FIVE EIGHT PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO NOW. AND WE HAVE ABOUT
FOUR IN THE QUEUE. THANK YOU
MARIE PLEASE OPEN THE LINES AND
CALL THE SUPPORT WITNESSES
INDIVIDUALLY. OUR WELFARE RUN
NUMBER SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CORRECT
ALL THE PER FROM DTLA HELL AND
LOS ANGELES- PROUD CO SPONSOR
IN STRONG SUPPORT. MAXIMO TO
LINE SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS RANDY
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION A VERY
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. MAXIM
OF CAROLINE TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. EMBARKING ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB TWO FIVE EIGHT THANK VERY
MUCH. AND MAXIMO TO LINE TWENTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MY NAME IS
TREVOR CAN BOOK THE LOS ANGELES
LGBT CENTER AND WE AS A CO
SPONSOR WE PROBABLY SUPPORT SB
TWO FIFTY EIGHT THANK YOU. AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AS A
REMINDER TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR AT
B. Q. FIVE EIGHT PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO NOW AGAIN LONDON ZERO TO
SHOW SUPPORT. AND WE DO NOT
HAVE ANYONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
MODERATOR HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
THE SUPPORTERS WILL NOW POLICY
PROCESSING CURE FROM. ANY
OPPOSITION- WE WILL WE WILL
BEGIN WITH ANY OPPOSITION IN
ROOM FORTY TWO ZERO THREE. SEE
NON MOVING ONTO ROUTE TWENTY
FORTY. SEE NON- WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO THE TELEPHONE PUBLIC
COMMENT LINE. MODERATOR PLEASE
PUMP INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF S. B.
TWO FIVE EIGHT PROVIDE THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE WAITING.
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. SHARE
ONLY AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO OPPOSE S. B. Q. FIVE EIGHT
PRESS ONE THEN NOW. AGAIN TO
OPPONENTS AT B. U. T. BY THE
PRESS ONE BEEN VERY NOW. AND WE
DO NOT SHOW ANYONE THE QUEUE AT
THE SMALL. THANK YOU MODERATOR
AT THIS. MOMENT I WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE- COMMITTEE ARE FOR
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ON
THIS BILL. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR PAN AND WOULD YOU LIKE
TO. CLOSE AN EARLIER. JUST
THANK THE WITNESSES AND DíAS
FOR AN IPHONE. SO WE HAVE A
MOTION BY CENTER PAN THE MOTION
TO PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS S. SECRETARY CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB
TWO FIVE EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
HER TADO. HI FOR TARO I JONES
NOT VOTING JONES NOT VOTING
CORTESE ALL RIGHT CORTESE ARE A
PAN AM I. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THE BOAT IS THREE ZERO ON S. B.
TWO FIVE EIGHT AND THAT BILL IS
OUT. AND NOW WE ARE MOVING
FORWARD TO ITEM NUMBER. FIVE-
SENATOR JONES WOULD YOU LIKE TO
BE PRESENT ON SB FIVE TO EIGHT
I WOULD LOVE TO PRESENT ON SB
FIVE TO EIGHT YOU CAN DO IT
FROM MY DESK WOULD THAT BE OKAY.
OKAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M
SURE MEMBERS SENATE BILL. FIVE
TWENTY EIGHT WILL TREATING
HEALTH CARE PORTAL. THAT WILL
ALLOW HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS TO
ACCESS IS ESSENTIAL MEDICAL
INFORMATION OF A CHILD IN
FOSTER CARE. FOSTER YOUTH ARE
FREQUENTLY FORCED TO CHANGE
HEALTH PROVIDERS AS THEY MOVE
FOSTER FAMILIES. FOR REASONS
THAT ARE BEYOND THEIR CONTROL
BECAUSE OF THIS THEIR MEDICAL
RECORDS LIKE THE HEALTH
EDUCATION PASSPORT. AND THE
JUDICIAL AUTHORIZATION FOR
PSYCHOTROPIC MEDICATION
PRESCRIPTIONS. ARE CRITICAL TO
THE CAN CONTINUITY OF THEIR
MEDICAL CARE. UNFORTUNATELY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR
PRICING MAYBE FORTUNATELY.
FOUND OUT THAT THESE RECORDS
OFTEN HAVE ERRORS OR ARE NOT.
GIVEN TO THE HEALTH PROVIDERS.
WHEN EVALUATING FOSTER YOUTH.
SOME RECORDS EVEN FAIL TO
IDENTIFY PSYCHOTROPIC
MEDICATIONS THAT COURTS HAD
PREVIOUSLY AUTHORIZED. WITHOUT
AN ACCURATE MEDICAL RECORD
FOSTER YOUTH FACE UNNECESSARY
CHALLENGES IN SEEKING MEDICAL
TREATMENT. ELECTRONIC PORTAL
CREATED BY SB FIVE TWENTY EIGHT
WILL ALLOW HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS
TO ACCESS THEIR HEALTH
INFORMATION REAL TIME. THIS
WILL REDUCE THE LOSS OF
CRITICAL HEALTH INFORMATION AND
ALLOW FOSTER YOUTH. TO RECEIVE
EXPEDIENT AND PRECISE
TREATMENT. I HAVE A TWO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
PRACTITIONERS. OUT THERE ON THE
COURT CO HOST TELECONFERENCE
LINE. AND THEY WOULD LIKE TO
SHARE THEIR REAL WORLD
EXPERIENCE. IN THIS MATTER
MELCHER THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER VICE CHAIR I DO WANT TO
STATE THAT S. FIVE TO EIGHT
DOES HAVE BY. SUPPORT AND WE
WILL NOW OPEN IT UP TO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION LEADER WITNESS AND
SUPPORT OPPOSITION WILL BECOME
A TWO THREE MINUTES EACH. AND
WE WILL BEGIN WITH- WHAT IS
NUMBER ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYBODY I AM DOCTOR ALEXANDER
PASTA WAIT PRESIDENT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF CHILD AND
ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY A PROUD
SUPPORTER OF SB FIVE TWENTY
EIGHT. AND A COMMUNITY CHILD
AND ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY AND
ADVOCATE FOR CHILDREN'S MENTAL
HEALTH. IN CAMPBELL COUNTY.
TWENTY SIX ANGEL DETAILED
MEDICAL LEGAL DOCUMENTS. FILLED
OUT BY THE PRESCRIBING PROVIDER
WHEN PRESCRIBING PSYCHOTROPIC
MEDICATION. TO PROSECUTE YOU.
THIS DOCUMENT TO THE CORE FOR.
OR DENIAL OF THE MEDICATION
EVERY SIX MONTHS OR A
RETIREMENT. IS AT OR CHANGED. I
HELPING EDUCATION PASS THE
BOARD IS THE HEALTH DOT.
DETAILING ALL CARE CAN BE AND
INTERVENTION INCLUDING IN
NINETY. WELLNESS CHECK.
MEDICAID. AND HOSPITAL A ABOUT
BOX CHILD THEY ENTER THE
PROCTOR. WE RIGHT I NEVER AND
FOUND THAT LAST 10% OF THE
CHILD AND I. HI AT TO PREVIOUS.
WHEN OR HOW AND EDUCATE PASS
THE BOARD ON INITIAL THAT. BOX.
WHEN THE SPOT YOU HAD BEEN ON
TRIAL MET. YEAR AND ON WELCOME
THANK WHICH WILL MEDICATION AND
THEY HAD ENACTED G. TWO TWENTY
APPROVED BY COURT OR MULTIPLE
GB. TO TWENTY. WE ARE SUPPORTED
OF THE BILL PACKAGE SO
HEALTHCARE. SUCH AS MY- COULD
HAVE WE PAIN TO THAT THE- HELP
IN AND. WITH WHICH WOULD
ARTISTIC MAKING COME ONE PER
SQUARE I CONTROL MEDICATION.
FOR SOME OF THE MOST FOR BLUE
IN STATE. EIGHT THANK YOU TO
JONES FOR AUDREY THIS IN. AND
WHITE J. BILL. AT THE REQUESTED.
TO HAVE COME COMMITTEE SUPPORT
TODAY THANK. THANK YOU ARE WE
WILL BE MOVED ON TO WHAT A
NUMBER TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS DR CREDIT FOR FASTER I
AM THE SECOND FOR THE- AND CAL
OF JAZZ AND THANK. AND I'M THE
CHIEF RIGHT OFFICER FOR THE
COUNTY OF MEDINA I HAVE BEEN
WITH THE OF BENITO. FOR OVER
TWO YEARS SERVING IN THANK. WE
CURRENTLY DO NOT HAVE. TO THE
MATTER OR PSYCHIATRIC HISTORY A
BASE ANY OF MEDICARE ARE FIVE
DO YOU THAT TAKE. THIS BILL
WOULD ALLOW. ACCESS TO THE
DIFFERENTIAL. AND HELP US VALUE
EIGHT DIAGNOSE AND THE ACCOUNT.
TREAT PLAN. NUMBER EIGHTEEN
OKAY. WHICH APPROXIMATE
THOUSAND PER YEAR. OF THOSE
ABOUT THOUSAND I FOSTER YOU.
FOR THE FIFTH THOUSAND. THAT
ARE NOT FIVE THREE YEARS WE
HAVE THE NECESSARY INFORMATION
TO APPROPRIATELY TREAT THEM.
BUT FOR THE FIVE THOUSAND FIVE
TO USE 18% OF THEM WHO ARE
TAKING PSYCHOTROPIC MEDICATION
WE DO NOT HAVE THE INFORMATION
TO PROVIDE THE BEST QUALITY
CARE THESE CHILDREN DESERVE.
THIS IS ANOTHER INEQUITY IN
HEALTH CARE FOR OUR POTS USED
TO TEND TO BE CHILDREN OF COLOR
ON THE NET THE NEXT AND THAT
COMMUNITY. THIS BILL WILL
ADDRESS. THE RACIAL INEQUITIES
IN HEALTH CARE FOR OUR CLIENTS
TO YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR JOHN ADVOCACY FOR OUR
MOST VULNERABLE CHILDREN AND WE
HOPE WE CAN COUNT ON THE
COMMITTEE SUPPORT TODAY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU- AT THIS MOMENT AND
WE WILL MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT
IN SUPPORT AND WE'LL BEGIN WITH
THE ROOM. FORTY TWO ZERO THREE.
SCENE NINE WE ARE MOVING ON TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE TO EIGHT SEE NON.
MOVING ONTO THE TELEPHONE
PUBLIC COMMENT LINE. MODERATOR
CAME PLEASE PUMP INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIVE TO EIGHTY AND
PROVIDE THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. LADIES AND GENTLE MEN
TO SUPPORT SB FIVE TO EIGHT
PRESS THE ONE THEN ZERO NOW.
AGAIN HE SHOWED SUPPORT FOR S.
B. FIVE TO EIGHT. PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO NOW. ONLY HAVE ABOUT
Q. AND THE Q. I. THANK MOTHER
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES AND
CALL THE SUPPORT- WITNESSES
INDIVIDUALLY PLEASE. SHARE
WELFARE WHAT NUMBER THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON KAREN NUMBER THANK
YOU DON'T ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
PSYCHIATRISTS IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. UNLIKE SOME OF TO
LINE FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIRPERSON AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS CHANCERAPS
ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WHICH
IS IN STRONG SUPPORT SB FACT
YOU. THANK YOU. AND ONCE AGAIN
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR AT D. FIVE TO EIGHT
CLEAVED PRESS THE ONE BUTTON
ZERO NOW AGAIN TO SHOW. SUPPORT
FOR SB FIVE HE LATE ONE THEN
ZERO NOW. AND I DO NOT SHINING
ON US IN THE QUEUE AT THE
MOMENT. THANK YOU HAVING HEARD
FROM ALL SUPPORTERS WILL NOT
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESSING YOUR
FROM UP FROM ANY OPPOSITION.
AND WE WILL BEGIN WITH PUBLIC
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION TO SB
FIVE TO EIGHT AND ROOM FORTY
TWO ZERO THREE. SEE NON- ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. THREE NINE WE
WILL MOVE TO THE TELEPHONE
PUBLIC COMMENT LINE. MODERATOR
PLEASE PUMP INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF SB
FIVE TO EIGHT TO PROVIDE THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE WAITING
TO TESTIFY. SURE SURE. AT YOU
FIVE TO EIGHT PRESS ONE THEN
THEY'RE ON THE- AGAIN WHO
OPPOSED S. B. FIVE EIGHT PRESS
THE. ONE ZERO. AND AT THE TIME
WE DO SHOW ANY AND QUEUE. THANK
YOU MODERATOR ARTISTS I BRING
AND QUESTIONS BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND WE HAVE-
CENTER PEN PLEASE FEEL FREE TO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MADAM
CHAIR AND- CENTER JONES THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD AS A TEACHER SINCE
TAKING CARE FOSTER USE- I THINK
A FACE SOME OF THE SIMILAR
CHALLENGES THAT SOME OF THE
WITNESSES TALKED ABOUT IN TERMS
OF TRYING TO GET FACTORED
HEALTH INFORMATION INCLUDING-
PRESCRIPTION DRUG MEDICARE
INFORMATION FOR. FOSTER YOU SEE
PARTICULARLY WHEN THE FIRST
PRESENTING TO OUR OFFICE. SO I
REALLY DO APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THIS BILL FOR I DO
HAVE A QUESTION FOR YOU THOUGH
IS- AND IN THAT ALSO MENTION
ANALYSIS AND WE KNOW THAT THESE
ASSOCIATES ARE AND ARE
ESSENTIALLY WARDS OF THE STATE.
AND WE WILL ALSO WON'T BE
SHOWING SURE WE PROTECT OUR
PRIVACY- SO- CAN YOU JUST MAYOR
PERHAPS COMMENT ON IT BUT IF IT
HAD THE OPTION HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS AND
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES IN
TERMS OF HOW WE HANDLE THIS
PORTAL. AND THE SORT OF FOLKSY
YOU PUT INTO IT TO BE SURE
THAT- THAT WE PROTECT THE
PRIVACY WHILE STILL ALLOWING
THE HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS ARE
ACTUALLY TAKING CARE OF THOSE
FOSTER USED TO HAVE ACCESS THAT
INFORMATION. YES THE THAT'S A
VERY IMPORTANT QUESTION AND
THOSE ARE CONVERSATIONS ARE
ONGOING THERE WE BELIEVE THAT
THERE'S SOME CURRENT STATE-
SYSTEMS ARE IN PLACE THAT WE
CAN- CANNOT. DEPRIVE PIGGY BACK
ON FOR LACK OF A BETTER TERM
ANSWER OPEN TO HAVE THIS MORE
DIALED OUT AS WE MOVE FORWARD
WITH A BIT PRIVACY CERTAINLY IS
A TOP CONCERN. AND I APPRECIATE
THAT I THINK YOU KNOW THAT'S
IT'S NOT BE SURE WE COULD GET
THAT COVERED IN THE IN THIS
BILL BUT CERTAINLY VERY HAPPY
TO SUPPORT THE BILL AND I WOULD
MOVE TO BUILD APPROPRIATE. TIME
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. DO WE
HAVE ANY AT THE- COMMENTS ARE.
FROM THE COMMITTEE. NO OKAY
MA'AM. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
HIS REST A PER THE- COMMITTEE
SUPPORT DOT PANTS WITH THE
MOTION AND ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE. SO WE DO HAVE A MOTION BY
A CENTER FOR PAN THE MOTION TO
PROSPER FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH. AND
CERTIFICATE PLEASE CALL THE
ROTH SB FIVE TO EIGHT. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH HER TADO. FIVE FURTADO
I'D JONES HI JONES I CORTESE HI
FOR TASTY I PAN. AM. NINE THE
VOTE ON S. B. FOR TO EIGHT IS
FOUR ZERO AND THAT BILL IS OUT.
AND AT THIS MOMENT WE'RE GOING
TO LIFT THE CALL ON. IT IS ONE
ONE IS. FOR THREE FOUR. SB ONE
ZERO SEVEN. SB TWO THREE FOUR
AND S. B. THREE EIGHT FOUR. US
SECRETARY CAME PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SB ONE ZERO SEVEN THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PAN. AND BY THE.
FOUR ZERO. THE BILL ON SB ONE
ZERO SEVEN AS FOUR ZERO THAT
BILL IS OUT. SB TWO THREE FOR
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HOUSING PAN HI. AM
I THAT'S A FOUR ZERO. AT THE
BOW IS FOUR ZERO ONE S. B. TWO
THREE FOR THE BILL ITSELF. SB
THREE EIGHT FOR. THE MOTION IS
DO YOU PASS AS AMENDED BUT
FIRST AMANDA AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY
PAN. AM I THAT'S A FOUR ZERO.
THAT'S AFFORDABLE AND THAT BILL
IS OUT. I WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE FOR THEIR PATIENCE
AND- TO BUY EXTRA TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS CENTER PAN TO
CENTER COURT AS HE FOR JOINING
US I HOPE THAT- YOU ENJOYED
YOUR FOR SPEED AND THERE'S A
LOT OF. GOOD THINGS TO GET FOR
US TO WORK ON HERE- ACT I WANT
TO THANK ALL THE INDIVIDUALS
WHO PARTICIPATE IN THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY AS WELL AND AS
AND ALSO BIG THANK YOU TO OUR
COMMITTEE STAFF- THE AMOUNT OF
HOURS AT THE WORK. NIGHT AND
DAY TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT THIS
WORKS- I IT'S THAT WORKS AT THE
COMMITTEE WORK THAT WORKS IN
BILL THAT WERE. BILLS I WANT TO
THANK YOU BOTH. I THINK
EVERYBODY ELSE AT THAT ALSO PUT
TOGETHER THIS THE SPEED PICK
YOU FOR ALL THAT YOU DO AND- I
ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT-
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WERE NOT ABLE
TO. TESTIFY TODAY TO PAY A BID
YOUR COMMENTS RESEARCH. IN
WRITING TO THE SENATE HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT. TO
US AS WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS. I THANK YOU
AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION AND ONCE AGAIN
THANK EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION. WE
HAVE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA THE
SENATE HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE
IS ADJOURNED.